hello everyone so i will talk about the
next the second program next
spring uh these are the list of the
five co-organizers and i want to draw
your attention to the fact that out of
the five three are in europe
and in fact the previous program i think
we had out of the five tour in europe
and that's an important feature that
i'll come back to
so i want to start by telling you what i
would call a tale of two volumes
so about 25 years ago
uh mit press published something a a
handbook of theoretical computer science
edited by anne van leuven
and it had two volumes volume a was
roughly i described it the theory of
algorithm so it was algorithm and
complexity theory
and and volume b is the more focus on
programs and system concurrency
semantics and the like
it turns out that uh for more complex
reasons that i have time to ex
to to to go into details now the north
american focus
is mostly on volume a that also means
that
traditionally most of the activities of
the summer institute
are focused on volume a and here there
was a particular effort to broaden the
scope and bringing volume b
and it means a heavier european presence
which given that we're going to be
virtually in the spring is going to be
a major major challenge because of the
time difference let's say between
the west coast and central europe
so what is the the main theme of when we
talk about theoretical foundation of
computer computer systems
when you develop algorithms and you want
to know
does the algorithm do what he's supposed
to do and what is the complexity of the
algorithm
when we build system and we write
programmable build system we have
some what we call designer intent the
designer has some functionality in mind
and we want to know that the system that
we build meet the designer designer
intent
so this is a does this does what we have
built is it correct this is a natural is
it calling
now of course you can ask what is
designer intent intent
is always an ambiguous thing what's in
your head what's what's the intent
so people usually put things down in
writing but you have
if you have seen i would say traditional
requirement documents are written in
natural language
and they are vague and ambiguous so
a proposal has been made many years ago
to try to have formal requirement to try
to have more
formal a list of properties that the
system is supposed to satisfy
and to use logic as a declarative
specification language
because logic offers us precise syntax
and semantics
i would say is the business success of
logic or first order logic in this case
has been
sql which is based on first order logic
so uh ted code proposed using
essentially first audio logic
as a query language for databases and
today this is industry
i think approaching 50 billion a year so
this was the major success
uh of course boolean logic were used for
circle design
and there are other logic that have been
for example logics as is called psl
properties specification language
a system verilog assertion sva the ieee
standards
that are based on temporal logic so so
this idea of using logic as a
declarative for this specification
formalism
has had quite a lot of success
so how do we so again the the driving
uh question one for for the theory of
system
how can we ensure that the system will
build meet designer intent
and now design and intent is written to
us in in some logic
in a in a declarative formalism and
to simplify things you can think of
three answers one is using
theorem proving techniques to prove
correctness
this is expensive but it's the biggest
biggest hammer you can have and it is
used by companies such as microsoft and
aws
is using it invested quite heavily in
this
the other other approach is algorithmic
verification
and here we use facebook facebook
and google and microsoft in eda tools
use algorithmic verification and the
final thing is algorithmic synthesis we
go directly from the the clarity
formalism
to the system we build and this is less
used in industry but is using academic
tools
so the two the important ideas here is
one is to logic
for formal requirements but the other
one is logic is a high level language
and automata is a low level language its
states transition
very very low level and the cooks is a
connection has been established
in the going back all the way to the 50s
between logic and automata
between a high-level formalism which is
logic
and and low-level formalism so the the
year
is going to be the the program is going
to explore uh
several themes of tfcs
one is the connection between logic and
automata
the again the the dichotomy between
optimistic behavior
and probabilistic behavior worst case
behavior essentially versus expected
time behavior
uh looking at system and their
environments as adversarial games
if the multi-agent systems again we look
at games we look at equilibria
and going from this kid behaving to
analog behavior dealing with real time
and energy consumption and the common
theme is the combination of
reasoning and automation automated
reasoning and there is a synergy with
the
first program that antonina talked about
satisfiability
also looks at automation of reasoning
and so the two programs have quite a lot
of overlap
thank you